all right bree
bree where are you from originally
where'd you grow up um i grew up
in a town called bhutan in new jersey
so what was your childhood like you have
both your parents
yeah i have both my parents um
we originally we moved from i was born
in florida
but we moved when i was a month old um
to a town called irvington
and i had my first
uh sibling born when i was six my sister
and their brother two years later we had
a really good childhood
everything was good
where did your life go after you left
home
um well
i ended up here i actually uh my husband
passed away two and a half years ago oh
sorry yeah
and um so i went to detox when i was in
new jersey
and i did that for a week and then i
actually flew right out here to
uh go to rehab in pasadena i'm supposed
to be there for a year
but um when the haze the fog kind of
lifted
and i like realized exactly what was
going on i left
the rehab after three days um i chose to
come to the one in california
hoping it would deter me uh from leaving
because i knew i'd have bad days and i
don't know anyone out here
um but i guess it didn't i just i left i
was just too
too much anxiety too much going on at
once
i had just lost my youngest son
you lost your son um yeah i have
four boys but the last one
i i was on heroin
when i found out i was pregnant with him
so um
i looked into rehabs and they got me in
a 90-day program and then when i was
about to graduate i still didn't feel
comfortable not being in an environment
like that
so they found a mommy in me it's where
you can have your baby there and keep
the baby with you
and i was just about to graduate
and i had a warrant for an old fine
um when i checked into probation it was
the week before my son's first birthday
so i had been with him that whole year
but um
he got put in foster care because i had
to go to jail
and i lost the bed at the mommy and me
they were gonna give me housing and
stuff like pay for the mortgage for like
five years
and i lost that i lost everything
and i was in they said they could only
hold my bed for three days
i ended up being in jail for 11. so
i lost my dad uh when i talked to
deifos it's the child protective
services in new jersey
asked how i you know where i go to pick
my son up and they're asking where was i
living now at this point i was kind of
like drifting
i wasn't allowed back home at that point
i was living with my dad my mom and dad
separated
when i was about 21 so my mom moved to
florida my dad stayed in jersey
i stayed with my dad but um
he put up with a lot for many years so
um
yeah he just couldn't do it anymore and
him and my sister taking care of my
three boys
so i didn't really have anywhere to
bring the baby to
and they opened a case against me anyway
for neglect
and i was like i don't understand i
never neglected him he's
with me 24 7. he said well in the state
of new jersey it's considered
um neglect if you go to jail and have
nowhere to
put your son so they're going to start a
case against me i just
had previously gotten my keys closed
with my first three kids they allowed me
to keep custody
after almost four years of fighting in
court because i would have a relapse
every so often and then it's like i'd
have to start all over
new counseling and parenting classes and
it's just every time you complete
something they want you to do something
else and it was really
really rough but luckily my dad helped
me a lot like brought me to appointments
and
stuff like that so as long as i agreed
to give up
uh 50 of my custody to my dad me and him
would split it so they said if god
forbid
i did have a relapse or anything were to
happen to me at least everything would
be okay like if they were with my dad
so i agreed to that but it was just so
like draining those
almost four years so i just i knew i
couldn't do it on my own
because my dad wasn't gonna go through
it again
so i just gave the baby up at that point
and the baby where is he now
i don't know
[Music]
he he went up for adoption
adoption my sister actually knows
where he is though because somehow it
was a closed adoption i wasn't supposed
to know anything
about it but somehow the family reached
out
to my sister and she she goes and sees
him for his birthdays
he just turned four and your other three
boys are where
my oldest son he's in the marines um
he's 20 and my middle two
my sister recently bought a house she
was living with my dad they were all
living together my dad's got a really
big house
but my sister bought her own house and
moved the two younger boys in with her
so do you talk to your boys
once in a blue i could i could
call them every day if i wanted but
they're older now
and i just don't have anything good to
say
i know it really hurt them when i left
the rehab because they're all so proud
of me
for going but
i just i hate calling them like i want
to call them
i want to talk to them all the time
but it was always the same thing when he
coming home
and i just hate it and then i never know
what to tell them
and they always just tell me like we're
praying for you
and they're older now i mean they sound
so
strong but i know like we were so close
i was with them always for the first
like basically
15 or 16 years
and it went from that to just not seeing
them at all the last day i saw them was
two and a half years ago at the airport
they came with me to say goodbye and how
long have you been down here in skid row
uh like yeah two and a half years
and you're living in a tent um no i'm
staying with a friend right now
i'm just kind of like drifting police
please so
i don't really get along with the guy
i'm staying with too much
like i haven't been home in like three
days
just because i can't stand fighting all
the time
so i've spent a week walking around
and just passing out wherever i
sit and what are you doing for money now
um process your name
how much money will you make in a night
not a lot
it's i mean that guy for like a [ __ ]
i asked for like 30
i'm like 50 for sex but i stopped having
sex
because i've had so many surgeries
recently on my knee
it's like it just irritates it
i don't really want it like doing it
anyway i don't get much more money to do
it so
i have people tell me all the time
because i'll tell them like how much i
hate it and like
you should find another profession or
something because you hate it that much
and i'm like i don't really know
any of the girls really that don't hate
it
i mean you got to pretend like you're
all right with it because who wants
you know nobody wants to sit there with
some uptight girls like complaining
about everything she has to do but i
i despise it it's just
i i've tried working and i just can't
pull off you know
eight hours and then waiting
two weeks for a paycheck maybe it just
doesn't work but this is like
if i get dope sick i go out and i can
get
you know 30 or 40 however much
money in like 10 20 minutes and you know
get paid immediately and
work at what times i want when i want
you know how much i want
it's quick and it's not easy but
uh like mentally i guess it's not easy
but i'm so used to it at this point it
doesn't really bother me
like if i sit there and actually think
about it yeah it bothers me but
it's just the easiest thing i could do
what is your drug heroin
when did you start using heroin
i think i was about
25. who introduced you to that
my old best friend she'd been doing it
for
um about 10 years
and every so often she's like begged me
to get high with her
and i just i didn't know much about it i
lived a really sheltered life my parents
really
were protective of me and but i just
knew
i guess i just knew better there was
nothing good that could come out of that
but
i suffered from a really bad anxiety and
depression
and i actually started taking pills
um xanax and like percocets or
any kind of pain medicine and
out of nowhere my doctor one day when i
came in for my refills just cut me off
like that day didn't even give me one
more refill i guess he was kind of
getting in trouble for writing too many
scripts from narcotics
because i tried uh a bunch of other
drugs before that
before heroin and i never it never
really did much for me i never
i could take it or leave it like i'd do
cocaine if when i was younger if we were
clubbing or
and that was it it would just be a night
of fun and i'd leave it alone
for months or however long so i just
thought it'd be like the same thing if i
was just really going
through it i'd just you know do a few
bags of heroin
and uh and stop it worked like that for
maybe six months like i was just doing
it here and there
and um then her husband showed me how to
uh
i was sniffing it in new jersey it's all
powder
one and um just my nose was starting to
get irritated
and like stuffy all the time i started
to get like a little stab
and um i just watched him shooting it up
and it just looked so much better like
you know take a little while to hit you
when you sniff it and when i'd watch him
shoot up he was instantly
nodding out so he actually
shot me up for the first time i remember
it was like new year's eve
and that was it it was like over after
that i was doing it every day
and i started stealing from stores to
support my habit and that
worked out for about i say good almost
two years
and i'm hiding it from my family and
but i picked my kids up from school
every day and
i got arrested for the first time like
i'm a little over two years into doing
it for ceiling
i think it was a walmart and it was
cutting it kind of close to the time
the kids had to be picked up i only had
like another two hours or something like
that
so i called my dad from the police
station
and i just immediately like
started crying and i told him i was in
jail
and he you know he's very like calm and
laid back and he's just like oh man
what'd you do
and i told him i was stealing and he he
was like stealing
like for what because at the time
i was babysitting a little girl
so i mean uh i think like 120 bucks a
day
um watching her and then plus i had a
boyfriend at the time
um he was working and i think he got
about four or 500 bucks a week
and all his check like he basically gave
to me
and then i'd hit up my dad for money all
the time
if we ran out so he didn't understand
like
why are you stealing like you have
plenty of money or you could if you
needed money that bad you could have
just called me
but i'd been really hitting them up like
hard lately and it was kind of like
where is all this money going what are
you doing and i'd just come up with some
excuse
so i told him like i would have asked
you but you've been saying no lately so
i just and i don't want to bother you
anymore
so i was just like stealing like
electronics and selling it to a police
that
buys that stuff so what does heron do
for you
um i used to say it takes away my
depression
[Music]
but it now just kind of feels good
and stops me from being sick i feel like
it does help with the depression still
but
when it comes to like my thinking about
my kids
it doesn't it doesn't take that away
i'm like miserable all the time
and i'm trying to get myself
to go back to rehab because my kids are
getting older now
the other two are 13 and 15.
and um i'm sorry the middle one turned
16.
and uh tony the little
one he'll uh his birthday's in april
he'll be 14. i want to get clean so bad
because the more time that passes
just like this life here has become
the new normal for me
i feel out of place and weird
when i'm around just average people
whereas this
type of setting used to like terrify me
and
make me sick to my stomach like feel so
sad for the people
walking down the street like i used to
drive to get my drugs
when i was in new jersey it was a really
bad um
part of town and i didn't even
i wouldn't even get out of my car in
those days
i was scared i just the guy would come
to the car and i'd just crack it open
just a bit and then be right out of
there
but it was like a few years later i was
just down there walking around
hanging out like it was nothing and that
felt okay to me and like now like
just going home for a day the day i was
leaving
for california like i just felt so weird
like being in my dad's house again and
seeing my kids every time i'd see
them it's just once in a blue and i
would just hug both of them
just hold them both over here
and i just i wouldn't let them go
and then just both like okay mom i think
my oldest son at that point
he'd just kind of be in his room he'd
say hi
and like we were so close that
i know it hurts him so bad and he
puts up to this front like
like he's not hurting but i know he is
he doesn't even want to talk to me
anymore
i called him last year on his birthday
just
say happy birthday and you know he
sounded all happy when he answered like
hey hello and i hear all his friends in
the background
i said hey it's mom and then click
and i say hey it's mom i just want to
say happy birthday and
he didn't say anything you just hung up
that was last time i heard his voice
the other two are much more
understanding but i think it's also just
because they don't
they don't know as much
you know they were younger when all this
was going on and my son my oldest son
was figuring it all out and thus his dad
would tell him stuff
and he knew way too much
and it hurt him
but he was such a good kid i remember i
was sitting
in his room on his bed one day when i
was
wanting to get high so bad but i was
trying to stay clean
and i was just crying and crying
and he came home from school and he he
saw me
and he he didn't even say anything he
just ran over to me
and he just hugged me so tight
and he was rubbing my head and you think
it's okay mom you're gonna be okay
it's like he didn't even know i was
crying why i was crying but he knew
he just looked at me and he knew and
he's such a sweet kid
so sensitive and he just hugged me so
tight he was just crying just just
because
i was crying
i miss that so bad
is this the lowest point in your life
right now yeah
it bothers me so much that like i was
saying i'm still going through like
terrible feelings and depression even
though i'm getting high
so i'm trying to just keep telling
myself that it's like
well i guess if i'm gonna be miserable
either way why can't i just go home
and be miserable i just like i'm
terrified of the thought of getting
clean
and having those feelings again just
like a deep like emptiness
and you know just being in bed all the
time and crying and
it scares me but i'm like what's worse
like that
or this like i'm still crying all the
time and
this is just as of since coming to
california like
before that you know i'd be away from
the kids on and off and
i was sad without them of course but it
coming out here it was like just real
that i was not with them anymore
and it felt like permanent and i just
became really
even more depressed about that and
it's just sad because when i was back
home like there was really nothing to be
depressed about at all i had a great
life
anything i needed i i got and
[Music]
you know i i had i had it all like
anything
anybody could want but it didn't matter
i was just sad i just
was clinically depressed you know just i
guess the chemical imbalance and
i i tried different depression meds and
different combinations they give me
but i never felt like it was a pill
really that was gonna fix me like i
needed to like make some type of
change like lifestyle change or
something
um so i'm just keep trying to tell
myself that like you know what are you
doing your kids are getting older and
older
i'm getting older it's just all these
times being wasted
for what and i know it's killing them
they put on their little brave face or
whatever but
you know they don't have their dads they
have two different dads neither
really have their dads um
and i was kind of all they had and
[Music]
they just i felt like we were just
unusually
close just like a bond so
i don't know like up until i left
pretty much they were still taking turns
like sleeping in my bed
and there'd be nights i'd wake up and
there'd be one on the bed and like
two on the floor because they just
wanted to be around me
always and i remember when i started
being gone more
my youngest one tony like
he i could tell he was starting to feel
something wasn't right even though he
was pretty young
and when i'd go to leave he would look
so sad and he'd be like
you're coming back right
i don't know why like i guess he
just sensed that i was probably
pulling away or
but it just kills me and i hurt
everybody so bad i'm just
i just want to make them all proud and
that's why i don't ever call because
i want to be able to call from a rehab
or from some good place
i want to be able to call and finally
say when i'm coming home
i just hate calling with the same old
nonsense like yeah still out here
still doing nothing and i
try to pretend like i'm not getting high
but obviously
everybody knew was better i would be
gone if i weren't getting high
but i try to play it off like to my dad
like
he doesn't know i live in on skid row
and
um i pretend like i live in a nice
apartment and have a nice job
just because he worries so much
i'm sure he probably knows i'm lying but
i i don't
he gets worried and i don't want him to
know that like
what a bad actual situation i'm in
thank you so much for talking with me
breese no problem
good luck thank you
thank you